[Background conversation]
>> OK. Dr. Ngozi Okonjo-Iweala
>>Hi you two, nice to talk to you, uh this
was sent you posted is what we've just been
discussing in two different for a here in
Davos. The first one is uh the prime minister
Gordon Brown divert a group of leaders to
talk about a call to action to reach the millennium
development goals. Uh these goals have to
do with Daven poverty, with making sure that
children get into school all children educated,
making sure that people get treatment for
diseases uh there is a caution maternal mortality
and infant mortality. We have to do this with
business leader. Business leader were there
like Bill Gate, John Chambers, coming together
with business and entertainment industry.
>> And red
>> And red, the right campaign from Bobby
Schriver. Uh, we are going to make a difference
in trying to bring all resources to bear on
this question. The second place is in education.
Business people, governments, uh, private
sector people, everybody. Civil society are
coming together to say how can we make sure
that we educate every child in this world,
no child deserves to be left behind. So this
is the answer to your questions, we are working
on it, it will be a coalition, a partnership
and we will get it done. Thank you.